et nous parlons à présent un politique
avec cette nouvelle nomination pour
othman amasseront soir aux reflets
blancs soir flora notman mastrou élus
d'opposition les républicains attrape
élus majoritaires à la région ile de
france il vient d'être désigné dans
cette assemblée donc au poste de vice
président chargé du tourisme et des
affaires internationales alors une
décision annoncée à part à valérie
pécresse en fin de semaine suite au
départ de david douillet alors pour être
bien clair un david douillet député de
la 12e circonscription ne quitte pas son
poste de conseiller régional juste cette
fonction il évoque un problème d'agenda
officiellement et ne plus assurer des
déplacements à l'étranger toutes les
semaines officieusement on comprendra là
que david douillet veut se consacrer à
sa campagne il a d'ores et déjà été
investis pour l'élection législative sur
le secteur de poissy plaisir alors on en
revient à othman moscou qui se voit donc
confier encore une fois de nouvelles
risque en font une nouvelle fois le
jeune élu de 29 ans prend du galon lui
qui jusqu'à présent on s'occupait pour
la région de la commission du
développement économique on rappelle
aussi que depuis les dernières élections
municipales à trappes où il a obtenu un
peu plus de 30% des suffrages
il détient aussi des responsabilités à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines othman nasri
est en effet le président de la
pépinière d'entreprises pour nos cols ou
pas mais effectivement j'ai moi je fais
pas de la politique depuis longtemps
j'ai un premier engagement
savéol à la trappe je suis toujours élu
ou doit toujours prouver lui vivre
l'opposition municipale cette ville en a
besoin et bon j'ai eu l'occasion de la
campagne des régionales
toujours sous la houlette valérie
pécresse m'a mis le pied à l'étrier là
dessus lors des foulées de confier de
nouvelles responsabilités j'espère que
du coup je donne une bonne image aussi
de trappes de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
du territoire ont montré que quand on
travaille sérieusement quand on essaye
de faire valoir certaines idées et bien
il peut y avoir aussi une reconnaissance
du travail accompli
puis le temps d'apprentissage c'est un
parcours et il va pas encore beaucoup de
choses le souhait de me rendre utile
je veux faire monter les jeunes qui le
méritent ce sont les propos de valérie
pécresse donc après cette nomination
othman nassau qui peut en effet remercié
la présidente de la région qui l'épaule
depuis c'est quasiment tous premiers pas
en politique
autre magnat souhaitait déjà pendant la
campagne des régionales
porte parole de valérie pécresse dans
les yvelines quant à ces nouvelles
missions voilà en quoi elles vont
consister dans l'axé international et au
tourisme de la région ile de france
recouvrant plusieurs l'attribution la
première pas mal être de par la
promotion du territoire à
l'international pour acculer à la fois
des investisseurs est bien sûr toujours
davantage de touristes puisque vous
savez que c'est un facteur important on
accueille plus de 30 millions de
touristes en ile de france a fait vivre
plus de 4000 personnes
et puis nous avons aussi des
partenariats des collaborations avec
d'autres collectivités territoriales
dans le monde donc il faut reconfigurer
pour certaines et dans tous les cas il
s'agit de de construire dans des volumes
de co-développement avec d'autres
territoires des partenariats qui sort
gagnant en gagnant gagnant simplement
connu qu'à la fois pour l'ile-de-france
avec mon entreprise francilienne mais
aussi pour ce territoire là ça peut être
en afrique par rapport à nos partenaires
en amérique du nord où on avis également
le fatah mais déterminé